on raconte que zeus le roi des dieux qui
s'était épris de rome une très belle
princesse phénicienne pris la forme d'un
taureau blanc pour la ravir et l'emmener
sur l'île de crète d'où leur fils
fondèrent la première civilisation
européenne mais ceci est une légende
je
nous
ce
notre histoire commence
il y a environ trente mille ans avec
l'arrivée de populations du genre cro
magnon nos ancêtres directs
nous sommes à la fin des grandes
glaciations les glaciers se retire vers
le nord et les hommes s'installent sur
le continent européen
s'adaptant aux ressources locales puis
ils se répartissent dans différentes
populations
chacune avec son propre artisanat et son
système des changes
ils pratiquent le culte de la fécondité
vivent en famille et commence à
domestiquer moutons et chiens
cinq mille ans avant jésus-christ de
dynamique foyer culturel se répand dans
différentes zones du continent et les
peuples s'organisent dans village
fortifié pour se protéger des nomades
le lin est cultivée pour en faire du
tissu la pop qui est largement produite
et distribuée les premiers centre
métallurgique de cuivre et d'or apparaît
ce simultanément et des normes
construction mégalithique à usage
astronomiques sont érigés sur les rives
de la mer noire vit le peuple
matriarcale des légendaires amazon et
dans les carpates
revenant des steps ukrainienne arrivent
les traces un peuple qui domestique le
cheval et instaure le patriarcat
guerrier à cette époque
les tensions menant souvent à la
rivalité et à la guerre naissent entre
les communautés qui maîtrisent déjà
l'usagé du bronze et d'autres qui ne
sont encore rares mais que de cuivre et
de pierres
la première grande civilisation
européenne l'ami noël se développe sur
l'île de crète et demeure florissante
pendant presque un millénaire
jusqu'à ce qu'un volcan sous-marin
explose ravageant ses côtes et mettent
enfin à son pouvoir
cela permet aux mycéniens un peuple
guerrier arrivée par le nord de
s'installer dans le péloponnèse et de
devenir une puissance maritime
d'envergure les mycéniens fondent des
colonies en mer egée construisent des
fortifications de grande taille situés
en hauteur et sont les responsables de
la destruction de trois
mais des tribus barbares les doriens
après avoir appris par les hittites de
mésopotamie à travailler le fer pour en
faire des armes envahissent la péninsule
grecque et écrase les mycéniens armé
uniquement de bronze qui ne peuvent leur
résister
le continent européen entre temps a été
occupé par des peuples dont les plus
puissants sont les ibères les
carthaginois les ligures les das les
étrusques
les germains
les bretons et les celtes
dans le péloponnèse les siècles obscurs
sont terminées les grecs se regroupent
dans cité état de même langue et de même
culture met souvent en guerre entre eux
les cités les plus importantes sont
sparte à la puissante armée et athènes
au commerce florissant
à cette époque en grèce ness le théâtre
la philosophie les jeux olympiques et
les premières démocraties à athènes le
législateur sol on rend le système
économique plus équitable
tous les citoyens ont la possibilité
d'exprimer leurs opinions et les
philosophes tente d'expliquer le monde
non plus par l'intervention des dieux
mais par l'action de loi naturelle
forts de leur puissance maritime les
grecs commencent à l'heure leur invasion
ils colonisent la méditerranée et écrase
les légumes dans tout le continent
les invasions se poursuivent avec les
carthaginois qui annexe les terres des
ibères et les germains qui envahissent
en masse les terres des celtes
certains peuples celtes sont ainsi
refoulé dans les terres des étrusques
d'autres vers les îles britanniques dans
la péninsule ibérique dans l'actuelle
france et d'autres encore jusqu'au quart
panne
voici qu'apparaît un nouveau danger
le puissant empire perse annexes l'île
de chypre
et un pack même la grèce
mais athènes le repousse regroupant
toutes les cités de la côte autour
d'elle gouverné par périclès athènes
connaît alors un véritable âge d'or
mais la rivalité et les guerre continue
contre sparte
ap bliss la péninsule grecque
cela profite à une autre puissance celle
du roi philippe de macédoine qui annexe
l'albanie du royaume illyriens la
bulgarie et la grèce à son royaume
le fils de philippe alexandre legrand
continue l'expansion macédonienne et
parvient à conquérir l'empiré perse en
étendant son autorité jusqu'aux
frontières de l'inde
mais à sa mort son énorme empire est
divisée
en italie une citadelle est en train
d'accroître sa puissance
c'est rome qui forment une redoutable
arme est écrasée et russes conquiert la
péninsule italienne détruit carthage
envahi la péninsule ibérique et la grèce
pour contrôler le pourtour occidental de
la méditerranée et avec les légions du
proconsul jules césar à nec semaine les
terres des celtes gaulois m'aide à son
retour à rome césar est assassiné
commence alors une terrible lutte pour
le pouvoir qui se termine quand le neveu
de césar
opta bien réussi à éliminer les conjurés
le sénat le nomme commandant suprême
militaire et religieux avec les titres
d'auguste et d'empereur et c'est alors
que la république romaine devient
l'empiré romain
rome poursuit ses conquêtes et annexes
la grande bretagne
et quand les das qui vivent l'âge d'or
de leur civilisation devienne une
puissance inquiétante
rageant les soumet les intégrant dans
son empire qui s'étend désormais
jusqu'au golfe persique rome assure
alors sa domination et sa flotte
contrôler les maires afin que le
commerce puisse se développer en toute
tranquillité
pourtant la longue faire romaine va
bientôt prendre fin
arrivant d'asie des hordes de mongols un
dévastent tout sur leur passage
il pénètre même dans les terres des
germains les refoulant dans l' empire
romain rome réagi promptement et
repousse des germains franc mais son
énorme empire est trop étendue pour être
bien défendu
qui est alors divisé en deux l'empiré
romain d'occident
avec pour capitale mediolanum l'actuel
milan rome étant devenu un centre
religieux chrétiens et l'empiré romain
d'orient avec pour capitale
byzance l'actuelle istanbul de
confession chrétienne mais orthodoxe qui
ne reconnaît pas le pape de rome comme
chef de l'église chrétienne
entre temps au nord la pression d un
d'athina ne laisse pas de répit aux
germains les suez et les vandales
refoulé hambourg la traverse pour
s'établir en espagne et en afrique
tandis que les airs hull poussé en
italie sa cage rome en déposant le
dernier empereur romain d'occident
mais byzance s'opposent
l'empereur romain d'orient s'accordent
avec le prestigieux peuple d'ego qui
transitaient sur son empire et leur
donne la tâche de libérer rome en
échange ils auront des territoires en vo
lego se remettent dont en marche des
arrivées en italie
il écrase les airs hull lui se divise en
deux peuples les wisigoths
qui joint aux dernières troupes romaines
vont chasser les uns pour enfin
s'installer dans le sud de la gaule et
les ostrogoths qui occupent italie
désobéissant aux ordres de byzance
pour l' empire romain d'occident symbole
de la chrétienté occupés par des peuples
barbares
la fin est désormais inéluctable
il retire ses troupes de la grande
bretagne
aussitôt envahi par les germains anglo
saxons qui donne à lille le nom
d'angleterre et abandonne la péninsule
ibérique et même la gaule qui est alors
envahi par les germains francs du roi
clovis converti au christianisme qui
repoussent les wisigoths en espagne et
donne à la gauche le nom latin de
francia